if you're looking for some powerful ways
to become your best self then this video
is for you
what's that believe nation at 7:00 my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out onto the world and so I've had a lot
of entrepreneurs write to me and they're
trying to discover themselves and
they're trying to figure out how to be
that best version of themselves and so
if that's you I'm going to share with
you my seven ways and how to discover
and become your best self way number one
is having self awareness I think it's
really hard to be your best self if you
don't understand what it is that you
stand for
I believe I wrote a book about it you're
one word everybody has one main core
value when you figure out what that is
you can go from a place of living your
life according to other people's
standards and what they want for you to
live in your own life and if you don't
know what you stand for then you don't
know what you stand against and then
you're willing to just do what everybody
else wants you to do and you don't have
barriers you don't have fences you don't
say this is what I am no longer willing
to accept in my life and this is the
path that I want to go down and so
having this self awareness to understand
who you are and what you're trying to
create for yourself the light that you
want to live according to the value
system that works best for you when you
know that it allows you to go so far so
fast compared to if you don't have that
understanding and so whether it's your
one word whether it's any personality
test whether there's other resources
that you want to look into it search
with understanding yourself all of the
strategies and tips and tactics in the
world will not help you until you how
the self-awareness to know who you are
as human being what you value most
having the clarity of what you want to
build will allow you to build it but
without that clarity then all the tools
in the world won't help you
[Music]
way number two is having an action plan
right you have to put together a plan
for how you're gonna build this great
life for yourself what does that best
stuff look like and then how am I going
to move towards creating it and I'm a
big believer in being able to find
people who've done it before modeling
success finding the people who have
already accomplished a thing that you
want to accomplish and then create an
action plan towards achieving it for
yourself because just understanding who
you are doesn't mean it that's gonna
happen just because you have a dream it
doesn't mean that that dream is gonna
happen you have to do the work you have
to create an action plan you have to
start working towards it understand that
no plan is perfect
don't spend days and weeks and years
making an action plan by the time you
finish your action plan is already
outdated and you have to go and do the
work and all your assumptions will be
wrong that doesn't mean the action plan
process is not relevant it's still
extremely valuable and it's important
that you do it that you put together
what a plan for the next month looks
like for you and then start actually
taking some kind of action on it right I
think that's where a lot of people fall
down they're so worried about having the
perfect first step and getting
everything all the ducks lined up
getting the perfectly aligned and know
that nothing will ever be perfect it's
going to be messy it's going to be
chaotic you're going to make tons of
mistakes and don't let the fear of not
having a perfect plan prevent you from
doing something so you're researching
your learning your model and success and
you're trying you're testing you're
seeing yes you're experimenting you have
to combine both of those things to
create an action plan so that the goal
that you have for yourself actually
starts to happen when number three is
have a supportive environment so once
you've identified what your one word is
and you've created an action plan again
it can be hard to actually get up and
execute the action plan on a daily basis
so what happens to a lot of
entrepreneurs is they start and they
stop and they start and they stop and
one day you're on fire and the next day
you're not the next year you know and
they're next to you not then you get
inspired and you're back on fire again
and next day or not right that's the
trend for a lot of entrepreneurs and so
what you want to do is create an
environment that allows you to be great
on a daily basis so for me my one word
is believe I've created an environment
that makes me feel like I believe in
myself daily if you look at my home
office you look at the people I have on
the wall you
the family have and on the pictures on
the wall and this stuff that you can't
see the shelves that I have and
everything in my home office is designed
to help me believe in myself so if I
wake up and I'm tired and I don't have
energy and I'm lacking that day which
happens a lot of mornings I don't wake
up super pumped and energized every
single day you may not believe it but I
don't I wake up I'm tired I walk into my
environment and instantly it supports me
to wanting to do something bigger to
believe in myself now a lot of people on
my wall may not resonate with you
probably you don't know who some of them
are and that's okay but them looking at
me moves me maybe pictures is not your
thing maybe you need music right maybe
you need books whatever the thing is
that helps you get going that that feels
you up with pride that lets you feel the
one word guy that you have whatever that
thing is then put that into your
environment so that it happens regularly
so that you don't have to think about it
that you can wake up and just boom there
it is it's in your environment when you
do that then you've removed the risk of
you not remembering to do something
you've removed the thought process
you've removed that thing of when you
wake up when your tires yeah I want to
go off and do that big thing and get get
yourself pumped up and inspired if you
remove that decision from you because
you'll let yourself down you remove that
decision take it out of your hands and
you're more likely to actually follow
through because it's just naturally
happening around you change your
environment way number four its surround
yourself with positive people you're
about to go on a quest and becoming your
best self you're about to shed the
layers and become who you're truly meant
to be in the process you are going to
get outside of your comfort zone you're
going to try different things and you're
going to change there are people in your
life that are going to love the change
and support you in it and there also can
be negative people in your life that are
not going to be very supportive of your
change so now it becomes a challenging
thing if those negative people are
people who are really close to you like
your spouse or your mom what do you do
if they're telling you that what you're
doing is stupid and it's not necessary
my suggestion is always over communicate
tell them why it's important and why
you're doing the
things that you're doing now even after
all of that they may not understand your
journey and you have to make that
judgment call yourself if this
relationship is important to you and you
don't want to lose a connection then you
might want to limit your exposure to
that person or if it's your husband or
wife maybe you don't want to share
everything that you're going through
with them because you don't want to get
into that fight but if your decision is
to completely get rid of those people
you could get a divorce or you could
never talk to your relative ever again
it's a hard decision but it's your
decision to make
once you have eliminated those negative
people in your life you need to replace
them with positive people who are
supportive of you and encouraging of you
you could do a couple of things that are
pretty easy
you could go on meetup.com and key and
the topics you're interested in to
connect with people who are like-minded
you could go on Facebook groups you can
even reach out to people whose message
really resonates with you to see if they
would meet up with you 101 now going on
a journey in becoming your best self is
an incredible journey but it doesn't
have to be a lonely one
you just have to surround yourself with
positive people way number five is to
adjust your habits so you are what you
consistently do you are what you
consistently do look at your habits look
at how you're spending your time and
chances are those things that you're
doing are leading to the results that
you're getting and so if you understand
what your core value is you understand
the world you're trying to build you
have a great environment now you're
around positive people what are the
other things what are the habits that
you need to change to build the belief
system in you and give you the
confidence to move forward so for me
it's the videos I love the videos it's
the book I read a page from the book
every single morning so that I open the
book it's in my environment so here's
the process I wake up I go to the
bathroom in the bathroom there's my book
there's a big glass of water and there's
a notepad I take a page from the book
and I read it and I think about it for a
couple minutes then I get up I drink my
glass of water and then I write down my
goals for the day it's in my environment
right I set it up the night before I
don't have to move I don't have to
change it it's a cue to remind me to
read the book I read the book I'm
surrounded now there's a habit reading
the book is a habit
the environmental cue is there I'm
reading the book I get inspired
legendary people here who are sharing
amazing ideas I get inspired it snatched
me out of the zone that I was in tired
waking up groggy to I want to do
something big today I have my videos on
my channel I wanted to be around people
who are doing much bigger things than me
I want to be surrounded by Elon Musk and
Steve Jobs and Bill Gates and Oprah
Winfrey and all these people who are
doing amazing things I don't have the
luxury or the opportunity to be mentored
one on one by Steve Jobs and it's never
gonna happen he passed away it's never
gonna happen but this is the next best
thing at least in my view right by
watching his content by seeing how he
thinks by making that a regular habit
consuming the videos on a regular basis
it fills me up with pride fills me up
with confidence and belief it teaches me
some new strategies and by doing that
consistently that habit allows me to go
off and have a great day and so you know
what you stand for you've created an
action plan you're around positive
people you have a fantastic environment
to support you now look at your habits
look at the things you're doing on a
daily basis do they move you forward
towards that best self towards creating
an amazing life for yourself or do they
keep you where you are and really doing
an honest audit of your habits will make
a dramatic impact on your life
[Music]
Wayne number six is have accountability
so even with all of these things
sometimes we'll still let ourselves down
right what still won't do the thing that
we say that we're going to do and what
really helps is if you commit to
somebody else you're much more likely to
follow through and that works in our
personal lives that works if we're
looking to go to the gym if you have a
gym buddy to go with you you're much
more likely to follow through if you set
up a meeting with somebody you're much
more likely to show up because we are
more likely to let ourselves down than
other people we don't want to let other
people down but we will continually let
ourselves down every single day and we
want to change that belief we want to
adjust our habits we don't let ourselves
down but you can also work with that so
that if you're committing to other
people tell other people what your big
goals are tell her the people your
action plan is and when you've committed
to them and you know they're gonna call
you on it you're much more likely to do
the thing that you said you were going
to do so I do in a couple ways I have a
online mastermind group I have an
offline
my group I have a YouTube master group
that I'm a part of and so knowing that I
need to report in knowing that I need to
share knowing that they're gonna call me
said hey Evan you said you're gonna do
this like three months ago and you still
haven't done it gives me a little bit of
an extra push to say I got it I got to
do it or Marc's gonna be all over me
like it was last time right and so
having people around you whether it's a
formal mastermind group whether it's
just a friend of yours to say hey let's
be writing buddies or let's be gold
buddies and call each other out don't
let each other off the hook right don't
say oh yeah that's okay I understand
this isn't just a support group it's a
getting stuff done group it's an
accountability group so that if you
continue to say you're gonna do
something and you don't follow through
that person's gonna call you on it and
make you feel a little bit bad for doing
it so the next time you're gonna meet
them you want to get it done because you
don't want to look bad again
so that whole idea of being judged by
others is not necessarily a fantastic
one to hold for the rest your life and
you also want to worry about like whose
judgment you're actually concerned about
but while you have it use it to your
advantage
commit to other people get some
accountability built in and it'll make
you much more likely to follow through
I'm building a life that you want
[Music]
and finally we number seven is get new
experiences a lot of times is easy for
an entrepreneur to get in a rut to feel
like you're doing the same thing over
and over and over again you wake up you
go to work you come back you wake up you
go to work you come back the activities
you do are the same day in day out day
in day out and that can be hard for a
lot of entrepreneurs because we like
variety we like trying new things who
like getting involved we like adventure
I'm speaking in generalities but a lot
of people can't just do the same thing
over and over and over and over and over
again every single day if we like that
we'd probably be great in the job and so
we don't want a job we want to have our
own business and so experiences can be a
great way to be able to help you see a
different perspective right it's not
that every day is a new experience but
you have your day to day you're doing
your grind you're your you're doing your
schedule you've mapped out your schedule
to it it matches what your ambitions are
you're you're grinding every day and
you're finding times to experience new
things to shift your level of awareness
for you to grow personally so example
last year it took my team to go see Tony
Robbins I took four of them down we had
a great time we brought that back to our
lives to our businesses to make a better
version of it for my filming here I
invited a bunch of people who are in
Toronto to come and say hi and watch me
film and somebody drove from Detroit you
spent five hours on the highway I had to
get a passport just to come to see me on
my filming day and we did a quick video
together doing stuff like that
stretching your comfort zone a little
but saying yes to new experiences it
can't be that every day is just a huge
adventure machine although if you're
trying to discover what you want to do
that's actually a fantastic thing to do
but being able to experience new
experience experience new experiences is
good it shifts your level of awareness
it introduces you to the new ideas and
it can get you out of the rut if you
feel like you're just doing the
day-to-day grind every single day so
those are my tips on the seven powerful
ways to be your best self I'd love to
know from you what was your favorite
we're trying to resonated the most with
you and why is there an 8 9 10 you want
to add to the list leave it down the
count's below I'm really curious to find
out thank you guys so much for watching
I believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever you're
one where it is much love I'll see you
soon raise your steel
dirty Apple at the core its core value
is that we believe that people with
passion can change not one drop of
myself work depends on your it's
something to me I don't ever give up I'd
have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
roses success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link in
description for details